[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Marietta Slomka guten
Abend wegen des bundesweiten Warnstreiks
standen Busse und Bahnen heute vieler
Orts still der dritte Streik im
Verkehrssektor in halb von 7 Tagen die
Gewerkschaft werdi hatte dazu in 15
Bundesländern aufgerufen wenn an anderen
Tagen der Bus nicht kommt liegt das ja
meist am Personalmangel im öffentlichen
Nahverkehr was auch keine gute
Voraussetzung für die angestrebte
Verkehrswende ist es gibt zu wenige die
ein Bus oder eine Straßenbahn fahren
wollen nach Ansicht der Gewerkschaft
liegt das auch an zu schlechten
Arbeitsbedingungen und Bezahlung
Scarlett Sternberg hat den Streiktag in
Hannover
beobachtet so du auch
eine Jörg Plesse fährt seit 7 Jahren
Straßenbahn belastend ist sein Job der
Krankenstand hoch in der Branche so
fordert er Entlastungen z.B für Schicht
und Nachtarbeit für sich und die
Belegschaft eigentlich will er seine
Fahrgäste zuverlässig von A nach B
bringen er fühlt mit seinen Gästen wenn
zunehmt schwierigere Arbeitsbedingungen
ihn zum Streik zwingen für mich ist
schon sehr sehr wichtig dass wir die
Bevölkerung mitnehmen weil ich auch
nicht nicht möchte dass wir dass
wir im Anschluss vielleicht nicht so ein
gutes Verhältnis haben wie was bis dato
hat um Menschen wie katlin Schulz macht
sich Straßenbahnfahrer Jörg pläe sorgen
eigentlich verbringt die Studenten in
der Woche 16 Stunden in Bus und Bahn
pendelt von Hannover zur Uni nach
Hamburg die Strecke mit dem Auto oder
das Parken am Hauptbahnhof kann sie sich
nicht leisten wenn der Nahverkehr
streigt muss kathlin zu Hause bleiben
Uni findet dann online statt
grundsätzlich kann ich die Bedürfnisse
verstehen und sehe die auch aber das
Pensum bzw die Regelmäßigkeit wie oft in
letzter Zeit gestreckt wurde ist einfach
eine enorme Belastung weil man einfach
seinem Alltag gar nicht richtig
nachgehen kann und man hat den Austausch
mit den komitonen einfach nicht mehr so
ein bisschen einfach wie in der Zeit von
der Pandemie wo man wo alle nur noch von
den vor den Bildschirmen sitzen wenn
durch Streik Stillstand herrscht kann
das für jeden einzelnen ganz
unterschiedliche Auswirkungen haben die
Serie von reereignissen die wir gerade
erleben gerade dann wenn sie so sehr in
den eigenen Alltag eingreifen kann uns
einerseits psychisch sehr belasten und
gleichzeitig ist aber die Möglichkeit
streiken zu können auch eine Perspektive
nämlich einer belastenden oder
vielleicht als ungerecht empfundenen
Situation persönlich nicht ausgeliefert
zu sein die Reallöhne sinken
Verbraucherpreise steigen jeder vierte
Arbeitnehmer bewegt sich mit unter 14 €
pro Stunde im Niedriglohnsektor und
viele Tarife Verträge laufen in diesem
Jahr aus für die Streikenden gute Gründe
wenn man sich die aktuellen
Arbeitskämpfe betrachtet dann entsteht
das Gefühl dauernd wird gestreigt es
wird nur noch gestreigt wenn man das
statistische Mittel nimmt dann befindet
sich Deutschland im Mittelfeld der
europäischen vergleichstaaten es wird
nicht besonders oft
gestreikt streikspitzenreiter ist
Belgien zwischen 2012 und 2021 wurde
dort durchschnittlich etwa fünfm so viel
gestreigt wie in Deutschland doch
Arbeitskämpfe bei der Bahn dem ÖPNV oder
dem Sicherheitspersonal an flughärfen
Lösungen sind bisher nicht in Sicht
eines haben aber die meisten Beteiligten
gemeinsam den Wunsch nach einem
schnellen Ende der
Streiks am Wochenende soll es land auf
Land ab wieder zahlreiche
Demonstrationen gegen Rechtsextremismus
geben eines haben sie bereits bewirkt
das Thema rechtsextremism ist stärker
ins öffentliche Bewusstsein gerückt bei
der Frage nach den wichtigsten Problemen
rückt es im neuen Politbarometer auf
Platz 2 und 79% der Befragten finden die
Demonstrationen gut die AFD wiederum ist
in der Wählergunst nach unten gerutscht
wenn jetzt am Sonntag Bundestagswahl
wäre würde sich die SPD auf 15%
verbessern die Union käme unverändert
auf 31 die Grünen verschlechterten sich
auf 13%. die FDP läge bei vier würde es
also nicht über die 5% Hürde schaffen
die AFD würde 3% Punkte verlieren und
läge bei 19 %. die linke und die Freien
Wähler landeten bei jeweils 3% und das
neue Bündnis Sara Wagenknecht schaffte
es hingegen auf Anhieb den Einzug in den
Bundestag mit
6%. Verluste also für die AFD doch auch
19% sind viel für eine Partei die der
Verfassungsschutz als Teilen
extremistisch einstuft in den
Parlamenten wächst die Sorge um die
Wehrhaftigkeit der Demokratie dort fber
bereichtet die AFD immer lauter immer
derber die Zahl der ordnungsrufe im
Bundestag ist stark gestiegen Die AFD
kassierte vergangenes Jahr mehr als die
Hälfte davon der Ton im Hohen Haus ist
äußerst gereizt seit ihrem Einzug her
Kollege bemkung in Richtung des Kollegen
diabi er könnne sich offensichtlich an
mitteleuropäische Sitten nicht
gewöhnenich ein Ordnungsruf jetzt strebt
der Bundestag eine neue Geschäftsordnung
an samt hohen Ordnungsgeldern das Ziel
zurück zur
Debattenkultur Herr Brandner
beispielsweise von der AFD schreibt dass
er der Abgeordnete mit den meisten
ordnungsrufen ist dass er darauf stolz
sei in diesem Hause und darf er gerne
sein aber diesen Stolz muss er demnächst
auch bezahlen das Wahlverfahren für das
Bundestagspräsidium soll mit der neuen
Geschäftsordnung ebenfalls geändert
werden die AFD Kandidaten fielen bislang
alle samt durch die Mehrheit im
Bundestag will sich aber nicht weiter
vorführen lassen weil wir momentan uns
dieses Schauspiel angucken müssen dass
wir nah zuu jede
Sitzungswoche Wahlvorschläge der AFD
erhalten und das uns auffällt und die
AFD das natürlich benutzt um ihre
Opferrolle nach außen zu dokumentieren
die AFD unterlaufe parlamentarische
Gepflogenheiten der Vorwurf und auf
diese Weise demokratische
Spielregeln das treibt auch die
Kultusministerkonferenz um denkbar wäre
nach den Wahlen in Ostdeutschland ein
Bildungsminister eine Ministerin aus
Reihen der AFD dann könnte die
Kultusministerkonferenz blockiert werden
die teils einstimmig entscheiden muss
von der Einstimmigkeit will sie jetzt
weg wir müssen uns so krisenfest
aufstellen dass eben einzelne
Bundesländer nicht in der Lage sind
Reformen im Bereich der KMK namentlich
zu verhindern und das ist der Grund
warum wir auch jetzt über die
Veränderung der mehrheitserfordernisse
diskutieren auch Landtage sehen
Handlungsbedarf Beispiel
nordrin-westfalen hier hatte die AFD als
ausschussschverständigen den Juristen
Ulrich fossgerau bestellt er war
Teilnehmer des potzdammer Treffens mit
rechtsextremen alle anderen Fraktionen
entschieden gemeinsam ihn abzuberufen
die Geschäftsordnung so dass das mit
einer zweirittel Mehrheit
geht jemand der an solchen Treffen
teilnimmt ist einfach persönlich nicht
geeignet in einer demokratisch
organisierten enquetkommission im
Landtag von nordrehein-westfalen
mitzuwirken das wollen wir nicht und
dafür dagegen wehren wir uns und das
sind die Schlüssel die wir eben daraus
gezogen haben es wird viel geredet über
Geschäftsordnungen in diesen Tagen denn
es gibt die Sorge dass die Demokratie
demokratisch ausgehüllt werden
könnte zu den Themen die Wasser auf den
möhlen von Rechtspopulisten sind gehören
die Probleme bei den Abschiebungen nicht
ohne Grund hatte Bundeskanzler scholzer
erklärt abgelehnte Asylbewerber müssten
im großen Stil abgeschoben werden in der
Praxis erweist sich das aber immer
wieder als schwierig etwa weil
Herkunftsländer die Rücknahme verweigern
oder weil ausreisepflichtige
Untertauchen das geschieht vor allem
auch bei straffällig gewordenen
Ausländern ob die verschärften abstie
Regelungen die heute vom Bundesrat
gebilligt wurden für diese Fälle
tatsächlich hilfreich sind das muss ich
erst noch zeigen Eva Schiller
berichtet umso krimineller umso
wahrscheinlicher ein Fall für den
sonderstab gefährliche Ausländer in
badenwürtembergs
Justizministerium Polizisten Beamte und
Juristen versuchen gemeinsam
Straffällige Einwanderer abzuschieben
die Fälle so schnell wie möglich durch
den Behördendschungel zu befördern für
uns ist es wichtig weil es uns über eine
Abschiebung sehr rasch gelingt wenn wir
irgendwo einen Brennpunkt haben wenn wir
einen Hotspot haben wenn wir es mit mit
gefährlichen Personen haben die halt
außer Landes zu bringen die Polizisten
im sonderstab dürfen nicht erkannt
werden weil ihre Arbeit mit
ausländischen Intensivtätern gefährlich
ist ein paar hundert Fälle bearbeiten
sie momentan größte Herausforderung die
Identität der Migranten nachweisen
sodass die Herkunftsländer sie
zurücknehmen muss schon sagen dass es
manchmal ein Stück weit auch die Suche
nach der Nadel im Heuhaufen ist in
Einzelfällen können es wirklich mehrere
hundert Arbeitsstunden werden die dann
in den Einzelfall reinfließen ihre
puzzelarbeit zeigt Wirkung macht aber
gleichzeitig deutlich wie schwer es
generell ist ob Straftäter oder nicht in
großem Stil abzuschieben das hat der
Kanzler vollmundig angekündigt in
Deutschland leben
243.000 ausreisepflichtige Menschen aber
80% haben eine Duldung zum Verbleib nur
etwa 16 000 wurden 2023 abgeschoben das
rückführungsverbesserungsgesetz soll das
eigentlich ändern die Abschiebehaft wird
von 10 auf 28 Tage verlängert es gibt
bessere durchsuchungsmöglichkeiten für
die Polizei Straftäter sollen leichter
abgeschoben werden aber Abzuschiebenden
wird ein Anwalt zur Seite gestellt
kontraproduktiv und zu kurz gegriffen
kritisiert die cduister überte Ende
werden Menschen die rückgeführt werden
ausgewiesen werden sollen werden in der
Regel dann gewarnt sein und nicht
anzufinden sein und das stellt das ganze
Ding wieder vor den Füßen auf den Kopf
ganz wichtig W das der Bund sich auch
mal um die Staaten kümmert wohin wir
nicht abschieben können beispielsweise
Afghanistan beispielsweise Syrien da
haben wir wirklich harte Straftäter
schwere Straftäter nur ein kleiner Teil
etwa 5% der Zuwanderer wird straffällig
aber wie verheerend die Folgen sind
zeigte sich auf besonders tragische
Weise in Iller Kirchberg ein
geflüchteter aus Eritrea er D 2022 ein
Mädchen auf ihrem Schulweg kurz darauf
muss die Gemeinde einen Vergewaltiger
aus Afghanistan nachdessen
Haftentlassung wieder aufnehmen
Lebenswirklichkeit und Rechtstheorie
gehen hier soweit auseinander dass ein
Erklärungsversuch voraussetzen würde
dass man selber versteht und wenn ich
verspreche dass man die abschieben muss
die hier kein Bleiberecht mehr haben
oder keine Bleibe Perspektive mehr haben
und das im Ergebnis nicht funktioniert
und die Menschen das vor Ort erleben und
sehen dann bröckelt Vertrauen in einem
Brief hat er die Innenministerin um
Hilfe gebeten die Antwort leider nichts
zu machen Markus Heusler Mast sich nicht
an schnelle Lösungen zu kennen er weiß
nur eins das spaltet auch wenn seine
Gemeinde im Schmerz
zusammensteht und jetzt geht's bei dir
erstmal weiter Hanna mit mehrwöchiger
Verspätung hat der Bundestag heute den
Haushalt 2024 beschlossen der et sieht
Ausgaben von rund
477 Milliarden Euro vor eine
Neuverschuldung von rund 39 Milliarden
Euro damit soll die Schuldenbremse
erstmals seit 2019 wieder eingehalten
werden auch der Bundesrat gab grünes
Licht für den Bundeshaushalt nicht aber
für das sogenannte
haushaltsfinanzierungsgesetz das unter
anderem einen Abbau der
Steuerentlastungen beim Agrardiesel
vorsieht dies wurde auf dem 22 März
vertagt noch eine weitere Vorhaben der
ampelregierung war heute Thema im
Bundesrat so beligte die Länderkammer
unter anderem die Reform des
Staatsangehörigkeitsrechts das neue
Gesetz sieht vor dass Zuwanderer bereits
nach fünf statt nach 8 Jahren Aufenthalt
in Deutschland Staatsbürger werden
können voraussetzung ist dass sie ihren
Lebensunterhalt ohne staatliche Hilfe
bestreiten eine doppelte
Staatsbürgerschaft wird grundsätzlich
möglich mit einem milliardenprogramm
sollen künftig Schulen in sozialen
Brennpunkten gefördert werden darauf
haben sich die Mitglieder der
Kultusministerkonferenz geeinigt das
Förderprogramm habe zum Ziel den starken
Zusammenhang zwischen sozialer Herkunft
und Bildungserfolg aufzubrechen in den
kommenden 10 Jahren wollen Bund und
Länder jeweils eine Milliarde Euro pro
Jahr bereitstellen profitieren sollen
rund 4000 Schulen und
Berufsschulen die israelische Armee will
ihre Militäroffensive gegen die
Terrororganisation Hamas im Gazastreifen
ausweiten betroffen wäre demnach auch
das Gebiet bis zum Grenzübergang rfach
im Süden dort halten sich
schätzungsweise zufolge aktuell bis zu
1,3 Millionen Menschen auf die meisten
von ihnen sind aus dem Norden vor den
Kämpfen geflohen die Bundesregierung
rief Israel dazu auf Zivilisten zu
schützen und mehr humanitäre Hilfe
zuzulassen in den USA steht der große
demokratietest im November an bei der
Präsidentschaftswahl die nicht nur die
Geschicke Amerikas entscheiden könnte
und sie könnte dabei eine Rolle spielen
Taylor Swift die Frau ist wahrlich ein
Phänomen derzeit der wohl größte Popstar
der Welt auf ihren Social Media Accounts
folgen ihr sage und schreibe mehr als
500 Millionen Menschen und seit kurzem
ist sie auch noch mit einem berühmten
Footballspieler zusammen mehr pomi geht
quasi nicht in den USA warum sie einem
Kandidaten Donald Trump gefährlich
werden können
sie ist das Problem zumindest wenn man
die Perspektive der trumptuen einnimmt
ihre Beziehung zur footballikone Travis
Kelsey ein weiterer
popularitätspush 2023 war Taylor Swift
der meist gesuchte Mensch auf Google
weit vor Donald
Trump sie kann Menschen milisieren wen
man sich sie mehr Frauen für Football
interessieren und zu den Spielen gehen
dann sollte einem auch klar sein welches
Potenzial sie hat für die Wahl 2024
junge Menschen und Frauen zu
mobilisieren wie groß Swifts Einfluss
ist zeigt unter anderem die Reaktion
ihrer Fans auf diese Instagram Story die
sie im September postet sie ruft ihre
Anhänger auf sich als Wählerinnen und
Wähler zu registrieren innerhalb eines
Tages kommen mehr als 35 000 Follower
ihrem Aufruf nach der Trubel um den
anstehenden Super Bowl bei dem ihr
Freund Travis Kelsey spielen wird noch
ein zusätzlicher Reichweiten
Boost die Aufmerksamkeit die Taylor und
Travis zur Zeit bekommen ist
außergewöhnlich und das führt dazu dass
die trumpanhänger vor Wut
schäumen 2020 warb Swift für die
Demokraten die Angst davor dass sie sich
beim Super Bowl vor rund 100 Millionen
Zuschauern wieder für Joe Biden
ausspricht für FT im Trump Kosmos zu
wildesten Theorien laut des
medienunternehmers Mike crisbyy sei die
nationale footballliga von der Regierung
gesteuert ein Moderator des trumpnahen
Senders Fox behauptet in seiner Show
Swift sei eine Agentin des US
Verteidigungsministeriums
verschwörungssaga im
magerlager die Leute die solche
Verschwörungstheorien verbreiten haben
selbst Millionen Follower online sie
sind auch oft Teil von Medienunternehmen
die ebenfalls innerhalb einer Woche
mehrere on Menschen
erreichen hinzu kommt dass die
trumpanhänger auf der anderen Seite
selbst kein Problem damit haben
Wahlkampf mit Weltstars zu machen
kidrock oder kan West sind die wohl
prominentesten Beispiele dafür Popkultur
als politisches
Kampfinstrument wie wichtig der Sängerin
politisches Engagement ist zeigte sich
unter anderem als sie sich 2018 gegen
eine republikanische ussenatsbewerberin
aus ihrem Heimat ST Tennesse
aussprach das ist für mich etwas
wirklich großes etwas Persönliches sie
setzt sich gegen fare Bezahlung von
Frauen ein sie stimmt gegen ein Gesetz
das Gewalt gegen Frauen eindämmen und
uns vor Missbrauch und Stalking schützen
soll eine aktuelle Umfrage ergibt dass
18% der amerikanischen Wähler für einen
von SWIFT bevorzugten Kandidaten stimmen
würden gerade im us-wahlsystem in dem
oft wenige Stimmen das Potenzial haben
alles zu entscheiden könnte also am Ende
tatsächlich mancher Swing state zum
Swift state
werden das lieferkettengesetz das
derzeit ja in der ampelregierung
gestritten wird soll Unternehmen dazu
anhalten ihre Verantwortung für Umwelt
und Menschenrechte nicht nur bis zum
eigenen Werkstor wahrzunehmen sondern
auch ausländische Zulieferer und Partner
unter die Lupe zu nehmen das ist
allerdings ziemlich schwierig wenn man
in sten produzieren lässt die
systematisch Menschenrechte ignorieren
und sich Einmischung von außen verbitten
etwa für deutsche Konzerne die in der
chinesischen Region chingyang involviert
sind Recherchen von ZDF und Spiegel
führen nun zu unangenehmen Fragen an den
deutschen Chemieriesen BASF Thomas
Reichard
berichtet Adrian Zenz der Uiguren
Experte hat so etwas nicht erwartet vor
ein paar Wochen kontaktieren ih ZDF
frontal und der Spiegel wir haben Fragen
zu einem umstrittenen Werk des
Chemiekonzerns BASF in der chinesischen
Provinz shinjan Zens macht eine brisante
Entdeckung auf den Webseiten des
chinesischen brsf Partners findet der
Berichte die ihn alarmieren wenn man da
mal auf den ersten Report drauf klickt
dann hat mir hier sofort den diesen
besonders kompromittierenden Bericht in
meinen Jahren der Forschungsarbeit zu
chinjang habe ich das noch nie erlebt
die brsf Fabrik sitzt in korla fast 3000
km westlich von Peking und mitten in
shinjang wo die muslimische Minderheit
der Uiguren seit Jahren systematisch
unterdrückt wird den heutigen
Vorstandsvorsitzenden von BSF Martin
Bruder Müller scheint das nicht zu
stören als er 2016 das Werk eröffnet in
korla stellt BASF Butan Diol her ein
Vorprodukt für Sportbekleidung der
Konzern erklärte acht die Menschenrechte
auch in Geschäftsbeziehungen doch genau
daran gibt es nun
Zweifel auf den Webseiten des BS
Partners der shinjang Mar chemical
industry findet uigurenforscher Zens
Berichte wie diesen im Februar 2018
fahren Marco Mitarbeiter zum
chinesischen Neujahrsfest in das Dorf
Aang sie sollen Uiguren überwachen es
gibt 24 Haushalte die gezielt
kontrolliert werden müssen bei der
Sitzung wurden besondere Vorkehrungen
für nächtliche Hausbesuche
getroffen die Mitarbeiter nennen sich
selbst fangu Teams ein Programm in dem
Chinesen sich bei Uiguren artieren um
sie
auszuspionieren anhand der von maror
selbst veröffentlichten Berichte ist es
offensichtlich dass Mar
Mitarbeiter direkt an nicht nur der
staatlichen Sicherheit und der
Überwachung sondern auch an Aktivitäten
direkt teilgenommen haben die der
masseninternierung der Minderheiten
dienten tatsächlich erreicht die
Verfolgung genau zu diesem Zeitpunkt
ihren Höhepunkt haben die Mitarbeiter
des BSF Partners dazu beigetragen in
almati Kasachstan treffen wir eine der
wenigen Zeuginnen die offen reden über
den Unterdrückungsapparat göpia
quasibeck flüchtete 2019 aus China für
Staat und Partei hat sie lange
mitgemacht bei Überwachung und
internierungen standen Z Busse bereit
jeder von uns bekam eine Liste ihr fah
an diese Häuser ihr an diese und nimmt
sie
fest B auf Nachfrage mitman prüfe das
Werk in K regelmäßig und werde das auch
weiter tun bislang hatten wir keine
Kenntnis von den genannten berichten von
2018 199 und den darin beschriebenen
Aktivitäten bei maror wir nehmen diese
Hinweise sehr ernst und werden Ihnen
weiter nachgehen Adrian Zenz sagt es
reiche nicht BF müsse sich sofort
[Musik]
zurückziehen so und dann gibt es jetzt
noch eine aktuelle Nachricht die uns
erreichtner sich vor starben ja mehrere
US-Soldaten als ihre Basis im
Grenzgebiet zwischen Jordanien und
Syrien angegriffen wurde und Präsident
Biden kündigte damals eine Antwort an
zumal er ja auch den Iran dafür
verantwortlich machte hinter den Gruppen
stehen sollte die diese Angriffe
ausgeführt haben und jetzt am Abend
meldet Washington dass die USA mit
airstrikes also mit Luftschlägen
begonnen haben auf militante das wird
sonst nicht näher noch erläutert im Irak
und in Syrien das ist Moment erstmal
alles was wir darüber wissen nachher im
heute journal Update spätestens gibt's
daran dann sicherlich noch weitere
Informationen jetzt geht's erstmal bei
dir weiter mit Nachrichten aus der
Wirtschaft Hanna ja ganz genau mit einem
Blick auf Deutschlands Maschinenbauer
die haben im vergangenen Jahr die
Konjunkturflaute zu spüren bekommen die
Aufträge sind 2023 deutlich
zurückgegangen und lagen 12% niedriger
als
2022 Frank betmann gibt es denn die
Hoffnung dass es in diesem Jahr besser
laufen wird nicht auch 2024 wird kein
einfaches Jahr für die Branche
zahlreiche Betriebe haben das Glück die
noch bestehenden Auftragsbestände
abarbeiten zu können aber das
Neugeschäft schwächelt die Kunden halten
sich weiter zurück so wie schon im
vergangenen Jahr in den großen
Absatzmärkten Europa den USA China fehlt
es an Vertrauen in einen dauerhaften
globalen Konjunkturaufschwung den gerade
die
Investitionsgüterindustrie benötigen
würde sagt der chefvolkswird des
Branchenverbandes Wichers der
exportorientierte Maschinenbau schielt
aufs Ausland hofft vor allem dass von
dort bald wieder mehr Bestellungen
kommen sicher aber ist es keineswegs
bestens war die Stimmung heute dagegen
auf dem börsenpaket es gab ein neues
Rekord hoch wie ist das zu erklären na
ja man kennt das ja wenn es irgendwo
nicht läuft wie beim Maschinenbau läuft
woanders besser vor allem die
sprudelnden Gewinne der großen
techkonzerne trieben heute den DAX an
zwischenzeitlich sogar auf ein neues
Allzeithoch bei über 17 000 Punkten doch
die Rekordmarke hielt nicht lang dem Dax
ging dann so ein bisschen die Puste aus
jetzt also heißt es Kräfte sammeln
nächster Anlauf vielleicht dann schon in
der kommenden Woche vielen Dank Frank
für deine Einschätzungen
gerne in der EU soll es bald ein Recht
auf Reparatur für viele Haushaltsgeräte
und Alltagsprodukte wie Smartphones
geben darauf haben sich die Unterhändler
des Europaparlaments und der EU-Staaten
geeinigt die neuen Regeln nehmen auch
die Hersteller in die Pflicht so sollen
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher einen
Anspruch auf Reparatur bekommen das Ziel
ist weniger Müll zu produzieren
Parlament und Mitgliedstaaten müssen
noch zustimmen dies gilt allerdings als
Formsache beim Auftag der schwimmwm in
Doha in Qatar haben die deutschen
Wasserspringer ihre ersten
medaillenschancen verpasst zur Halbzeit
lag das mixteam um Lena Henschel Elena
Wasen Timo Bartel und Moritz Wesemann
noch auf dem dritten Platz am Ende
reicht es dann aber nur für Rang 4 den
Sieg nach den Sprüngen aus 3 und 10 m
sicherte sich Großbritannien beim Einzel
landete Deutschland auf Platz 4
über das neue Politbarometer haben wir
ja am Anfang der Sendung schon berichtet
alle Fragen und Ergebnisse präsentiert
ihn jetzt Matthias
vnos guten Abend willkommen zum
Politbarometer es tut sich was im Land
hunderttausende Menschen gehen auf die
Straße um gegen Rechtsextremismus zu
demonstrieren eine frisch gegründete
Partei hat die politische Bühne betreten
und will künftig
mitmischen politisch bewegte Zeiten also
die sich auch in unserer Projektion
spiegeln wenn am Sonntag Bundestagswahl
wäre Kämme die SPD auf 15% + 2 CDU CSU
unverändert auf 31 die Grünen auf
13%-1 FDP unverändert 4 die AFD rutschte
ab auf 19% -3 die Linke 3 freie Wähler 3
beide -1 das BSW 6% +
2 damit hätte die Ampel weiterhin keine
parlamentarische Mehrheit als politisch
denkbare Bündnisse WD es für schwarzrot
oder schwarzgrün
reichen stabil bleibt die
Unzufriedenheit mit der Regierung zwei
Drittel der Befragten finden die Ampel
macht ihre Arbeit schlecht allerdings
glauben fast genauso viele dass es die
Union nicht besser machen würde die hat
eine politische Zusammenarbeit sowohl
mit den linken als auch mit der AFD
abgelehnt 64% der CDU CSU Anhänger
finden es richtig jede Zusammenarbeit
mit der Linken
auszuschließen 20% nicht bei der AFD ein
noch deutlicheres Bild
88% lehnen eine Zusammenarbeit ab 11%
finden das
falsch die große Mehrheit der Befragten
ist sich einig sollte die AFD im Bund
mitreieren würde das zu einer
schlechteren Politik führen gegen
Rechtsextremismus und die AFD sind
zuletzt Hunderttausende auf die Straße
gegangen diese Demonstrationen finden
die meisten gut eine Mehrheit glaubt
aber dass sie die AFD nicht schwächen
oder gar keine Auswirkungen haben
werden 72% sagen die AFD ist eine Gefahr
für die Demokratie ein Viertel der
Befragten sieht das anders dennoch
finden nur
41% dass sie verboten werden sollte mehr
als die Hälfte ist
dagegen seit wenigen Wochen gibt es eine
neue Partei die die deutsche Politik
aufmischen will das Bündnis Sarah
Wagenknecht BSW eine Protestpartei mit
Positionen mal links mal rechts aus dem
Stand
erfolgreich immerhin 19% der Befragten
würden sicher oder wahrscheinlich bei
der nächsten
Bundestagswahl BSW wählen das würde am
Esten der AFD Schaden 41% der AFD
Anhänger überlegen ihr Kreuz beim BSW zu
machen sollte das tatsächlich so kommen
könnte das BSW die Parteienlandschaft
ins Rutschen bringen nach der Europawahl
im Juni will sich das BSW auch bei den
Landtagswahlen in Sachsen Thüringen und
Brandenburg zur wahlstellen ob Frontfrau
Sara Wagenknecht in Ostdeutschland
selbstantritt ist noch
offen schauen wir auf unsere Liste der
wichtigsten Politikerinnen und Politiker
die wir immer die Befragten
selbstbestimmen auf der Skala von +5 bis
-5 bewertet nach Sympathie und Leistung
alisweidel bleibt Schlusslicht - 2,5
schlechter davor Olaf Scholz -1,1 etwas
besser Christian Lindner -0,8 deutlich
besser Sara Wagenknecht
-0,7 Robert habck -0,6 beide besser
annaalena berbor -0,6 leicht verbessert
davor Friedrich März -0,4 etwas
schlechter auf dem dritten Platz Markus
Söder 0,1 etwas besser das erste Mal
dabei Hendrik wüst Regierungschef in NRW
0,7 ganz vorne weiterhin Boris vistorius
1,6 leicht
besser auf dem EU-Gipfel diese Woche hat
Ungarn überraschend seine
Blockadehaltung aufgegeben damit ist der
Weg frei für 50 Milliarden Euro Ukrain
Hilfen aber nicht nur finanziell braucht
das Land Unterstützung die Befragten im
Politbarometer stehen hier weiter an der
Seite der Ukraine zwei Drittel finden
der Westen soll das Land wie bisher oder
sogar stärker als bisher militärisch
unterstützen der weil startet Russland
offensiven an allen Fronten ein Ende des
Krieges ist nicht in
Sicht
42% sind der Meinung die Ukraine soll
auf die von Russland besetzten Gebiete
verzichten wenn W so der Krieg beendet
werden kann
43% denken die Ukraine sollte weiterhin
um diese Gebiete
kämpfen dieses Jahr bringt für die
Ukraine viele Unsicherheiten wie lange
werden die Verbündeten zu ihr stehen der
bange Blick richtet sich vor allem
Richtung USA was wenn Donald Trump
tatsächlich Präsident
wird dass er Präsident wird erwartet
mehr als die Hälfte der Befragten nur
knapp ein Viertel geht aus dass die USA
dann immer noch die Sicherheit Europas
garantieren würden die große Mehrheit
glaubt das
nicht nicht nur für die Ukraine auch für
uns ist dieses Jahr also mit einigen
sicherheitspolitischen Risiken
verbunden das war unser Bericht über die
Stimmung im Land die Grafiken und alle
Informationen zu unseren Umfragen finden
Sie wie immer im ZDF Text ab Seite
165 in unserer ZDF heute App und auf ZDF
heute.de wie die repräsentativen
Umfragen der Forschungsgruppe Wahlen
zustande kommen Informationen zur
Methodik und zu den Qualitätsstandards
finden Sie unter
politbarometer.zf.de vielen Dank für Ihr
Interesse das nächste Politbarometer
gibt's dann am 23 Februar nach dem
Wetter geht's hier gleich weiter mit der
heuthow Ihnen noch einen entspannten
Abend auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend in den zentral und Nordalpen
hat es in diesem Winter viel geschneit
jetzt kam Neuschnee dazu das
Wochenendwetter wird ruhig perfekte
Bedingungen für Skitouren wenn Sie
vorsichtig sind abseits der Pisten
drohen Lawinen besonders gefährlich
Triebschneeansammlungen starker Wind
treibt den Schnee an Wind abgewandten
hangseiten in Mulden zusammen die
triebschneedecke hat eine gewellte
Oberfläche sie ist nur sehr lose mit dem
Altschnee unten drunter verbunden
besonders wenn der oben vereist ist die
Schneekristalle sind nach dem
windtransport verformt ineinander
verhagt und stark verbunden sie bilden
gefährliche enorm große Schneehaufen die
sich spontan lösen
können oder eben durch eine geringe
Zusatzbelastung wie sie ein einzelner
Mensch darstellt und es liegt ja viel
Schnee besonders in den Nordalpen und am
Wochenende gibt es eine leichte bis
mäßige Lawinengefahr und das Wetter wird
einfach toll Sonne und Wolken klar wird
es heute Nacht sein hier am Alpenrand
bei Temperaturen von 1° in der Mitte
bildet sich etwas Nebel über den Norden
ziehen Regenwolken hinweg bei milderen 9
bis 7° und morgen wird ein trüber
Samstag mit etwas Regen oder Nieselregen
für die meisten von uns bei Temperaturen
so zwischen 7 und 12° die Sonne bekommen
sie zuugesicht zwischen dem oberrein und
dem Berg des Gardner Land aber auch an
den Küsten von Nord und Ostsee am
Sonntag wird es etwas kräftiger regnen
und die neue Woche startet sehr mild mit
Höchsttemperaturen von 6 bis 15° schönes
Wochenende